Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE radical
Republican congresswoman, said yesterday that
Tucker Carlson's filing firing by Fox News
was illegal.
Now, she doesn't use the word illegal, but
it's really important to understand when these
people on the right say that was a violation
of the First Amendment.
They are saying that it is against the law,
what took place.
We're going to look at a video clip of Marjorie
Taylor GREENE explaining, I guess, her perspective,
if you can call it that.
What is really important to understand is
that when she says Tucker's First Amendment
rights were violated by Fox News, she's saying
it was an illegal firing.
These are the people who hold as one of their
most important stated values, low business
regulation.
Let businesses do what they want to do.
Law and order.
We need to unburden businesses from government
limitations.
They should be allowed to do what is best
and most profitable for them.
And here, she says, a firing by a private
company was unconstitutional and therefore
against the law.
We're going to break it all down.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Big news of the week.
Fox fired Tucker Carlson.
Fox has gone left.
They've gone.
Woke.
We're clearly calling them out for it.
Tucker is a great voice.
Speaker 4: For conservatives across the country.
Speaker 2: He doesn't have the platform anymore.
When you weigh in on Fox's decision to fire,
probably one of the more conservative voices,
most important voices in America.
Absolutely.
I think it was devastating to our First Amendment.
Eric, I see it as a very serious problem.
Our First Amendment is free speech, but it's
also freedom of press.
And when a gigantic media company like Fox
News fires their number one.
Tucker Carlson, not for him doing anything
wrong, not because his ratings were bad, but
they literally fired him because they came
to the mob.
Speaker 1: Now, that's completely untrue.
Tucker Carlson caused a multi-hundred million,
if not multibillion dollar problem for Fox
News.
Fox News made this decision based on money.
Not only was Tucker's program partially responsible
for the news coverage that got them sued by
Dominion and Smartmatic and so far led to
a nearly $800 million lawsuit settlement,
rather, in favor of dominion.
He also is being sued by a former staffer
for alleged discrimination and sexism and
so on and so forth behind the scenes.
He potentially will have caused another lawsuit
by Ray Epps that may be forthcoming.
This was a financial thing, but that's not
the focus of this segment.
It's Marjorie's misunderstanding of the First
Amendment.
Speaker 2: What we're seeing is we're seeing
the end of the First Amendment.
That's how we got it.
I can't see it any other way.
We've seen censorship out of control.
We we saw the federal government, Department
of Homeland Security align with big tech to
censor Americans for several years now on
political issues because they weren't speaking
the speech.
That was the chosen speech to say.
Well, neither was Tucker Carlson.
Tucker Carlson was pushing the limit every
single night on his show, and he was telling
the news stories that the American people
wanted to hear.
I also want to point out that many Democrats
even watch Tucker Carlson.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So the question here is, is there
any way in which a company company firing
an employee could violate the First Amendment
the way Marjorie Taylor GREENE says the First
Amendment of the Constitution to the Constitution
protects individuals?
And in theory, companies as well, from government
actions that interfere with freedom of speech,
religion, press, assembly and petition.
Private companies.
Private companies are not bound by the First
Amendment in the same way.
And on the other hand, they also generally
have the right to set their own rules and
policies.
This is something that people like Marjorie
Taylor GREENE on the right claim to revere
as one of the highest goals and virtues of
the United States legal system.
And this applies to employment as well.
Now, could firings be illegal?
Sure.
There's all sorts of wrongful termination
that that can and often is argued by by employees.
If Tucker were to be fired because he's white
or because he's Christian, certainly he would
have a very good case for wrongful termination.
I don't believe it would have anything to
do with the First Amendment.
It would violate employer nondiscrimination
law.
But the idea that because they fired Tucker,
the First Amendment has been violated merely
because Tucker spoke on TV is ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
And it shouldn't even be.
The sad thing is that we have to explain it
in this way.
Now, is there any way is there any way where
a company could be violating the First Amendment
rights of an employee?
Imagine that an employee speaks out about
a matter of public concern as a citizen, and
their speech isn't related to their job duties
in any way.
You can try to argue that your First Amendment
rights were violated.
It's very tough to do if it's a government
job.
It's slightly easier to do, but it's a tough
it's a tough standard to reach.
Some states have laws that protect employees
above and beyond the First Amendment.
Like, for example, some states have laws that
prohibit employers from retaliating against
employees for political activity outside of
work.
So that would be a situation where there is
an additional protection and the employee
would be able to hold their employer to account.
Do any of these circumstances even remotely
apply to Fox News firing Tucker Carlson?
Not Absolutely not.
Absolutely not.
And so we are faced once again with this question.
Do right wingers not actually know what the
First Amendment does and what it is, or do
they know but they realize their followers
don't, and so they blatantly lie to them on
TV.
I don't know.
You be the judge, but what we do know is Marjorie
Taylor GREENE is humiliatingly wrong here.
Today, I'm going to be speaking with Max Burns,
who's an award winning Democratic strategist
and also founder of Third Degree Strategies.
Max recently wrote an article asserting that
we may we may finally be at a tipping point
when it comes to gun violence and gun safety
in the United States.
We're going to talk about that.
Max, great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Thanks so much for having me.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, listen, my audience
knows we've heard this so many times before.
This this is definitely a tipping point.
You know, Sandy Hook was a tipping point or
Pulse nightclub or whatever else the case
may be.
Even popular reforms like a background check
as a requirement for any gun transaction,
including private person to person sales.
Very popular with the American public after
Sandy Hook can't get it done.
So I think people would be right to be skeptical
that we are now at a tipping point so late
laid out for us.
Why now?
What has changed?
Speaker 4: Well, you're absolutely right.
I think the gun violence conversation has
been one that's been littered with disappointments
from the beginning.
But what we're seeing now is a really interesting
confluence of factors.
One is that even though Congress is essentially
useless on gun policy right now, we're seeing
a real golden age of Democratic lawmakers
in states passing legislation that would have
been unimaginable even a few years ago.
Gretchen Whitmer, for example, just passed
an 11 bill gun reform package that would have
ended her career back in 2008.
Now they're talking about her as a potential
candidate for president.
The other side of this is the NRA.
They are in freefall.
And what was once the biggest gun rights group
in America can now barely afford to keep the
lights on in its office, much less fund the
candidates that have distorted this conversation
for decades.
So there's this this unique window of weakness
on the right and strength on the left that's
really creating a unique space for a gun conversation
that leads to actual legislation.
Speaker 1: I think a couple of the difficulties
are and part of this relates to what is or
could be done at the federal level and what
is or could be done at the state level.
A lot of this right now, for example, when
you talk about the Gretchen Whitmer package,
we're talking about the state level.
And here there is a sort of like moral hazard
situation where the state's most willing to
deal with this stuff often are the ones that
already are kind of ahead on the stricter
side when it comes to gun safety as it is.
So then when we think about, well, how do
we deal with this issue in South Carolina
or Texas, we start to think federally.
And one of the difficulties about federal
gun safety legislation is that running on
it for national candidates often isn't a great
idea from a strategy perspective, which I
would be glad to let you speak to as well.
But we there's this idea and maybe it's true,
maybe it's not, that when you run national
campaigns, including for like Senate.
Right.
Because you're in D.C. but your constituents
are in your state, that when you talk about
gun safety regulations, you rarely bring new
voters to support you, but you often activate
people who disagree with you.
And so there's that difficulty of saying,
well, the way to get Texas and West Virginia
and South Carolina to do something is to go
federal.
But campaigning on this stuff federally often
backfires.
So how do you do that?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I think that's a great point.
And one of the interesting challenges here
is that for years Democrats were sort of bought
into this Republican message that it was political
suicide to talk about guns in a campaign.
Right.
I remember following the Virginia Tech shooting.
Democrats came out the day after to publicly
reassure America that they wouldn't dream
of passing any gun control legislation.
And now those same people are leading major
campaigns in states and federally on gun reform.
And that's in large part due to the rise of
groups like Everytown Moms Demand Action,
These new groups that have sort of adopted
the right's organizing approach for this.
And we see that now that the majority of Americans
have in some way been touched by gun violence.
Numbers in support of gun reform are at record
highs.
And we're seeing that really start to break
down the old coalition.
In Tennessee, the Republican governor, Lee,
is supporting red flag legislation.
In Utah, the Republican governor, alongside
Everytown, passed a bunch of gun reforms that
make it tougher to get a gun and require background
checks.
And that's a coalition that was unimaginable
even a few years ago.
The Republicans are seeing the pressure mount
and actually realizing it's safer to take
incremental gun safety steps.
This is a completely different landscape than
I think Republicans are used to playing in.
And it's one where Democrats can actually
talk about guns and find that people are agreeing
with them for the first time since 1994.
Speaker 1: What is the timeline on which you
think we could see action on some of these
areas?
Speaker 4: I think it's much quicker than
than we think if we're looking at states.
The more that we've organized and this is
a really key part of every town, is they are
funding state races, they're cheaper, they
have a bigger impact on actual legislation.
And we're seeing that start to create a momentum
for national change once red states, which
are disproportionately affected by gun violence,
have seen that these things work, they're
actually pretty excited to talk about them.
And that's something that we're seeing distorted
by the gun lobby.
But when voters go to the polls, they are
voting on this issue.
It's a big reason why.
You see Joe Biden has gone from saying he
won't talk about social issues at all in 2024
to opening with an ad that talks heavily about
gun violence.
Democrats can see it's a winning issue and
they're for once really finding their voice.
Here.
Speaker 1: We have in the United States sort
of three separate gun issues.
You have mass shootings.
You have individual homicides affecting one
or two individuals per incident, and then
you have suicides using firearms in thinking
about.
And the prescriptions would be different for
these three different categories.
If we think about mass shootings for a moment,
I've put out a list of ten or 12 different
ideas that would never eliminate every mass
shooting, but would certainly do something
to reduce the number.
And there are some trends that we see when
it comes to the mass shootings.
Age of the shooter, typically under 25 type
of firearm used, often an assault style rifle.
You know, there's these trends that we start
to see.
What's the lowest hanging fruit in your mind
that would blend the most effective changes
that could be made with ones that are most
likely to actually be politically viable?
Speaker 4: Well, I think there's this unique
moment here that we see with Tennessee, with
Utah, with North Dakota that's talking about
raising the age for gun ownership, that you
combine background checks, which we've seen
even in in Michigan was a hugely popular thing.
Universal background check used to be a consensus
Republican position in the Bush administration.
They have gone so far off on that that it
doesn't resemble anything Americans want.
But you combine that background check legislation
and red flag legislation and you have immediately
handled two of the most vulnerable populations,
people who are going to use their guns for
violence against others knowingly at the time
they buy the gun.
And people who are going to use it for self
harm disproportionately young people.
And in rural communities, in agricultural
communities, huge rates have gone suicide.
And it all has to do with gun access.
And we can talk about making sure guns aren't
in the hands of kids without talking about
these Republican conspiracies of stealing
everyone's guns away.
And we're finding that the space for that
conversation is getting bigger every.
Speaker 1: Year when it comes to the next.
What's remaining, I guess I would say, of
the Biden first term.
And, you know, we'll see whether there's a
second term and sort of what framing he uses
for the 2024 campaign, given the circumstances
in the House and Senate, Republicans controlling
the House, Democrats controlling the Senate
at this point.
What's your sense of at the federal level,
what might be possible?
Know, I understand you're saying that Senate
Republicans I'm sorry, that state Republicans
to some degree seem more willing to take action.
What about things that would have to go through
the House and Senate?
Speaker 4: So that's the really big sticking
point here, is that Republicans have already
said that the bipartisan gun bill that they
gave Joe Biden is it for them.
They do not want any more.
So it's going to be basically a status quo
situation until voters in 2024 can be heard.
Yeah, And one of the reassuring things we're
seeing is that just in the same way that Beltway
consultants said don't talk about abortion
in 2022, it'll be polarizing.
But that turned out to be one of the leading
issues for voters.
We're seeing the same thing now with guns.
And it's one reason why Joe Biden, who is,
as I'm sure you would agree, very risk averse,
is comfortable opening his reelection campaign,
talking about gun violence.
Speaker 1: Do you have any insights and this
is getting very specific now.
You know, there's something we can look at
the gun safety issue, mental health, video
games, all the stuff that is always thrown
around.
But there is something intangible maybe about
American gun culture that doesn't exist in
some of the other countries with relatively
high rates of gun ownership.
Wherein I don't know.
It's just sort of like it's more common in
the U.S. that someone would see firearms as
a way to solve a personal problem and interpersonal
problem, a societal problem that doesn't seem
to be the case in many other countries.
Is there anything that can be done to restructure
that relationship between Americans and guns,
which seems to be sort of like a layer that's
above all the policy that could be put in
place?
Speaker 4: There is.
I mean, it's fundamentally a constitutional
issue.
I'm old enough to remember when people were
blaming video games for violence.
But the problem has always been that guns
in this country often have more rights than
the people they're killing.
And the fact is, the position has moved to
such a maximalist one on the right.
That doesn't reflect anything.
Even a few years ago that the court held on
guns.
There is now essentially Republicans arguing
for an unlimited right to own any gun that
you want.
And they're saying that anyone, even Republicans
who propose commonsense limits, are against
democracy and against the Constitution.
And it's polarizing people to violence, because
when you're told your fundamental rights are
being taken by a tyrannical government that
justifies almost anything in order to protect
your rights.
And we're seeing that happen.
I mean, we're seeing form of MAGA voters in
Nevada who shot at elected officials they
thought were stealing an election until the
Supreme Court or Congress gets some constitutional
momentum to rethink the madness of our current
interpretation of the Second Amendment.
It's tough to get anything long term accomplished.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask you about.
I have heard from many progressives, including
friends of mine, but also people who just
call in to my show who express views very
similar to mine on the issue of gun safety
and what they would like to see, but also
don't like the idea of the right wingers being
the only ones with the guns.
And so they have armed themselves, particularly
in the last few years.
They have become progressive gun owners, gladly
willing to subject themselves to background
check, mental health, civil liability insurance,
all the things we would want to put in.
But they don't like the idea of the right
wingers being the ones who disproportionately
have the guns.
Have you seen this?
Have you heard it?
Is it a race to the bottom or a logical reaction
to what we're seeing out in the world?
Speaker 4: Oh, I've absolutely heard it.
In fact, I believe the fastest growing group
of gun owners is black women.
And they're doing this in response to the
increasing racial polarization and race baiting
on the right.
And I'll tell you one thing that is sure to
get us into the courts is the idea of black
people owning guns is not something Republicans
consider to be the Second Amendment.
We saw that with Philando Castile, who was
an NRA member that they did not stand up for
at all.
The quickest way that we can get to a meaningful
gun reform conversation is for Republicans
to get scared at all of the non-Republicans
who are buying guns.
But it to me, a completely rational response,
and it's a sign of government policy failure
that people feel the need to have multiple
guns to protect themselves from their own
government's inability to act, to protect
them.
And we should be ashamed of that.
Speaker 1: We are going to link to Max's piece
about this issue.
We've been speaking with Max Burns, who's
a Democratic strategist and also founder of
Third Degree Strategies.
Max, really appreciate your time and insights
today.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much.